Okay.
Um,
by the way,
there were big trouble over the weekend,
uh,
in a,
in a suburb next week.
The last day I'm going to
talk about the problem.
So called problem of,
of the suburbs.
There's a big problem the other night
and when the policeman ran down,
um,
two kids on a scooter,
a screw town,
and they were both killed apparently.
And so there's a lot of
riots again going on.
So you can again,
you can follow us if you
know French on a f on false,
do TFL and um,
or in the restroom.
But this is a,
but this will probably,
this will probably be in
the newspapers anyway.
So what I want to talk about today,
uh,
it's hard to do both of them in one day,
but let's go,
is to compliment your reading on,
on a decolonization,
uh,
and talk about Vietnam and Algeria.
Uh,
and the subtext,
obviously it's not,
it texted intended in the,
you know,
in this course,
but is that the Americans
never learned the mistakes,
uh,
from which the French finally learned.
I next week I,
or next Wednesday,
I'll talk about about Charles de Gaulle,
but mostly about after he
comes to power in 1958.
But he's obviously important,
uh,
in this,
um,
you know,
from the beginning that it's after
World War Two that most of the colonies,
uh,
in the world became independent
in a process that took a decades.
Uh,
and of course,
the 1960s pick,
the beginning of the 1960s,
it's a very,
very crucial for,
uh,
in the case of,
of um,
uh,
of Africa.
Um,
and this,
despite,
uh,
despite the insistence of a,
of a Winston Churchill for one,
that the British empire
would not be a dismembered,
uh,
in Britain.
This transition,
uh,
from colony to independent state,
state often replete full of,
of problems came without
violence came generally,
uh,
without,
without insurrection.
Uh,
this was not the case with France,
nor as you know,
some of you,
not the case.
I was in Portuguese from
Portuguese colonies.
Uh,
uh,
as well.
Uh,
the Netherlands and Britain both resisted,
um,
independence movements before,
uh,
before a caving in.
And by 1980 a year that
I can even remember,
uh,
not with pleasure because
I was married that year.
Um,
more than half of the hundred and
54 members of the United Nations,
uh,
had been admitted to membership since 19,
56.
Now,
one obvious point is that part
of the dismantling of empires,
uh,
the,
one of the important theme in
this is that Britain and France,
uh,
in the postwar period,
became a less important
powers than they had,
uh,
before,
is that,
uh,
as you know,
France and,
and this was the essential and the goals
view of themself and view of the world,
uh,
seeks to retain its role as a great power.
But the world had basically been divided
up in the cold war between the Soviet
Union,
uh,
and,
the United States.
Uh,
and that both of those powers are,
we're competing aggressively for
these newly independent states,
uh,
in Africa,
in Asia,
and indeed in,
uh,
north Africa as well.
Um,
and so World War Two accentuated,
uh,
the independence movements that developed,
after World War One.
The case of Vietnam is of course,
just classic,
uh,
in that,
and you had a well organized,
uh,
nationalist communist movement
ready to assume the mantle of,
of yet the Movement for a Vietnamese,
um,
independence.
Um,
and,
uh,
as you will know that,
you know,
will Woodrow Wilson,
the spouse nationalism as ways that we
determine to determining the existence or
the creation of states.
And so Wilson and his American
successors were kind of caught in a,
uh,
you know,
caught in a trap because
on one hand they're saying,
oh,
yeah,
we need to,
uh,
we need to recognize
independence movements and
people to see themselves as a
single nation ought to have the
right to have their own state.
Uh,
but then because of the domain of,
of him,
because of the Cold War,
the Americans often found themselves,
uh,
acting in ways that,
that they,
um,
uh,
did not match a match.
Their rhetoric.
Um,
the,
the French left Syria and Lebanon by
agreement made with United States and
Britain,
uh,
after the war.
Uh,
but the problem of Vietnam and
the problem of North Africa,
uh,
as you know,
where the French had been since,
uh,
18,
30 would be a much thornier now ho ci men.
I mean,
I can,
you know,
I can remember,
I can remember this,
uh,
sort of a time warp for someone like me
cause I can remember all the marches and
was in all the marches against,
uh,
against the war.
You know,
back when I,
when I was your age and you know,
the chance of [inaudible] men NLF is,
is going to win.
Um,
he had become president of the Democratic
Republic of Vietnam after the war.
A hoochie men's,
uh,
father was an official under,
under the French under French rule.
And he had resigned from his
position because he had become a,
a Vietnamese,
uh,
a nationalist and Holcim men.
And there were other nationals of,
by the way,
I mean was one has a tendency to say,
well,
you know,
they get the communist party
representative nationalism,
but there are other nationalists to who,
who,
who weren't communists but
the war because the war end,
the war where the work comes out.
[inaudible] one ends
up talking a lot about,
uh,
about,
um,
communists nationalism.
But he had been working on a kitchen
helper on a French passenger aligner,
a crossing the oceans before
becoming a communist activist.
And he founded in 1929 the Ho
the Indo Chinese Communist Party,
which he founded in Hong Kong in 1929 in
1930 unified three groups of Vietnamese
communists around his leadership.
He was condemned to death in absentia,
uh,
by the French government.
And he was saved by the refusal of the
British government in Hong Kong to turn
them over to the French
because he would have been,
he would have been executed,
but that without any question.
Uh,
but he was arrested by the British in
1931 and he remained in prison in Hong
Kong until 1933.
Uh,
and during World War Two,
he led the Viet men have yet.
And then m I,
N H A in organization of
Vietnamese nationalists,
some of whom,
but as I said before,
not all of whom were communists.
Now I'm the French attack,
the port of high flying and he's got,
these are names,
you know,
out of my past.
I wasn't,
you know,
did not know about Haiphong.
I was a couple of years old then,
uh,
not even that,
I guess,
uh,
killing 6,000 Vietnamese.
And they captured a annoyed
the Vietnamese capital a and a,
this is after the war.
And so France restored,
uh,
the nominal authority
of a playboy emperor.
Uh,
and,
but the whole Holcim is Vietnamese army.
I held most of the countryside
rather like Mousay tongs army,
uh,
in China.
I've had begun,
uh,
during the war against climate and
Dong A to carve out huge sections of,
of,
of Chinese territory as well.
And Ho was supported by
the Chinese communists.
Um,
and he prophesies you
will kill 10 of our men.
Uh,
but we will kill one of yours.
And in the end,
we will end up by wearing you out.
Now,
this was,
this was the origins of,
of at least in the modern
era of a guerrilla warfare,
uh,
French intellectual who still
live in called [inaudible].
Hey wrote a very important book that I
remember I had to read in the seminar on
revolutionary elites with Arthur Mendel
at the University of Michigan called
high evolutional dorms.
I to shown a revolution in the revolution,
uh,
about a gorilla fighting.
Now,
if you go back those that go
back to before 1871 and 70,
71,
uh,
you remember what,
what the,
the Spanish,
um,
uh,
patriots were able to do in a,
in Spain against Napoleon's
occupying forces,
which was to pick them off one by one.
And the French retaliated by shooting
down civilians as they did in Calabria in
the south of Italy and other places.
Uh,
but you know,
we will,
you will kill 10 of ours and we will kill,
uh,
one of yours and Annette.
And eventually what happens in,
in the Vietnam case,
I is that,
uh,
as in the Algerian case is that the
pressure to pull out of the war becomes so
enormous,
uh,
that that strategy wins and
that the costs of continuing,
uh,
to,
to fight,
to battle,
to repress,
depending on your view of the matter,
uh,
will affect the home
front and the Home Front,
uh,
will,
demand,
uh,
the end of,
of the,
of,
uh,
of the fighting and indeed of,
of the empire.
Uh,
early in 1954,
the French army suffered a major defeat
at the hands of the Vietnamese at a
place called den Bn Ph.
You at the end,
uh,
which,
is now a tourist site for
lots of French go there.
I've never been there.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
there,
there is just as Vietnam has become,
you know,
the major,
Major,
sort of,
uh,
of tourist center and for,
you know,
oddly,
not oddly enough,
but I suppose it's good and bringing
these things to an end for lots of
Americans who fought over there.
Uh,
and some of them lost your loss
limit over there to go back.
And,
and to put at least
closure on all of that.
Pr Mendez Foss,
who was the new socialist premier,
uh,
succeeded in,
in taking France out
of the war in Vietnam.
And as you know,
he would be successful with a very
less successful and try to convince the
French to direct milk as opposed to wine,
a hopeless task.
And,
and,
uh,
he,
without question became the most,
uh,
you know,
the,
the most eminent French politician,
uh,
not to,
hold,
uh,
not to hold,
um,
uh,
power as,
as,
as president,
uh,
in France.
Did you a convention that year,
a frantic green to divide Vietnam
into two states on North Vietnam,
uh,
became a communist regime led by hace men.
Uh,
the capital of Hanoi and South Vietnam
became a republic run by a success
succession.
I think it's fair to say
a pretty corrupt leaders,
uh,
who carried out a u s,
policy,
uh,
in exchange for,
um,
for a free hand,
uh,
in,
in all of that.
Now,
one thing that was going
on behind all of that,
uh,
is the dissatisfaction of the army,
with what happened in
Vietnam now because the army,
which had been,
uh,
emerged from World War One,
victorious,
but ultimately France was less
powerful than Germany in defeat.
Germany had been in defeat
France and victory was less,
less powerful.
Uh,
had been defeated and many officers,
uh,
argued that it was the
collapse of the homefront that,
uh,
federal brought this about.
And if they had been,
uh,
actively by a over the long run,
if enough resources had been thrown in,
then,
uh,
victory could be achieved.
Now,
if that doesn't sound like Vietnam in
the late 1960s and early 1970s a time
that,
uh,
nobody in this room except two of us,
I remember,
uh,
cause that's exactly the same scenario
and it's exactly the same scenario now,
but that,
that's another,
uh,
that's another matter.
Um,
and so,
um,
therefore a France gets out of Vietnam.
And,
uh,
one of the things that happened,
by the way,
my friend Mark Lawrence,
it's an excellent book on this,
is that already that the French and the,
and,
and the British and the late 1940s,
we're getting the IC.
Uh,
we're getting the,
uh,
getting the Americans to
kind of do what they wanted.
But what happens then is,
is that when,
you know,
when the French are gone,
uh,
then,
the communist insurgency in the north and,
and,
and the Viet Cong in the south,
uh,
lead to,
this bloody a series of,
of,
uh,
of just horrible years in which so many
Americans and so many Vietnamese died.
And they are a commemorated by my,
I Mulind some islands,
uh,
a wall in,
in,
um,
uh,
in,
in Washington,
uh,
with their names on it.
And,
um,
that,
I mean that you can remember
those scenes of the frantic,
frantic,
and when the,
you know,
the healer copters or are,
are pulling off the,
the well,
uh,
the well healed and the
well connected from,
uh,
from Saigon and the,
in the,
in the very end.
And it was a lesson that was,
uh,
that was not,
there was not,
that was not learned.
And,
uh,
sometimes that's the way that things go,
but that was nothing compared to,
uh,
to,
Algeria.
Um,
that was nothing at all.
And one of the big differences why,
what happened in North Africa to above
all in Algeria occurred is that Vietnam
for all of the residuals
of French architecture,
uh,
you know,
building a,
a cathedrals and opera houses
along French architectural lines.
There's a wonderful book
by a woman called Winland,
right about imperial architecture.
I,
and there were a good
number of French living in,
in Vietnam,
uh,
but that,
Vietnam was not a settlement colony.
Uh,
the way that,
for example,
Australia and New Zealand had been in the,
in the British empire.
Um,
but Algeria was,
and so was,
uh,
Morocco and North Africa,
and,
uh,
Tunisia where settlement colonies,
all sorts of people
live there from France.
And they were called cool.
We're settlers basically.
And their nicknames were the PM.
Why Pa?
Wow.
The Blackfeet.
And there are several interpretations.
Uh,
maybe Brian can a illuminated us,
but sometimes they're called black feet.
Uh,
because of the boots,
uh,
that the army soldiers a war or because
it was thought that if they walked over
the burning sands of,
of,
of the Sahara,
uh,
you know,
that their feet would be burned
and therefore become a newer,
uh,
but they were settlers.
They were people who had been there
in many cases for generations and
generations.
Now,
Algeria,
as Charles told you,
and you already know,
uh,
was first conquered in 1830,
Jay Algiers falls,
uh,
in,
in June,
end of June or early July,
I can't remember which,
18,
30.
Uh,
and it's pacified.
That is,
you know,
lots of people are slaughtered,
uh,
over the next,
decades,
uh,
in 1851 after the insurgency,
to defend,
uh,
the democratic and social republic
against this and before this course.
But it's still important,
uh,
against the coup d'etat of,
of Louis Napoleon Bonaparte,
who became Napoleon third.
Many of the people who were arrested
and put on trial court martialled
essentially before what they call mixed
commissions were sent to Algeria either,
uh,
as prisoners in Algeria,
or just simply kicked out.
And then in a whole variety of ways where
a essentially allowed to take lands to
be gay that belonged to,
uh,
the Arab and Berber populations.
Uh,
and,
uh,
therefore they are there.
Um,
and one of the things about imperialism
is that this sort of social imperialism
that,
that Algeria was sort
of a safety valve that,
you know,
people who couldn't find work
or couldn't survive often,
you know,
when to Algeria because there,
it was sort of like the far west,
the image of the far west and the u acids.
There is a place you can get land,
you know,
you can get,
uh,
you know,
you can,
uh,
plant vineyards.
Uh,
you can plant fruit and,
and you will have a life,
you could buy a cafe and
you will have a life.
And so it was much easier to get out of
Vietnam because you didn't have a lot of
French people living in Vietnam.
And many of the people,
uh,
in,
in Algeria,
I did not want the French to pull out a,
they associated the
empire with their lives.
They were French in Algeria,
as you know,
from reading chips,
uh,
books.
How or why this book,
who's retiring,
he's just retiring as a party for him,
I think today at the
University of Melbourne,
um,
uh,
that,
you know,
they,
they were,
I lost my sentence there,
but they were,
uh,
they were there and their
empire was their lives.
The French empire was,
uh,
was their lives.
Um,
and so,
uh,
you got a 1 million French,
originally French,
uh,
people,
living in Algeria.
You have 200,000 in Tunisia and
you have 300,000 in Morocco.
Um,
and so they poured
money into their cafes,
uh,
in an LG I in Algiers,
um,
uh,
into,
their farms into their
economic activities.
And they were there,
some of them were very wealthy,
big land owners.
They were called the goalpost tall,
you know,
the big guys,
sort of,
uh,
and they,
were determined that,
that France would stay in Algeria.
Algeria was France French,
or they were opposed by the fl and the
frog deliberate [inaudible] Nasional,
uh,
which was,
very similar to the Viet Cong,
the Viet men,
uh,
in,
um,
uh,
in Vietnam.
Um,
and the resistance was also very,
uh,
as one would reasonably expect,
with Islam,
with,
uh,
the Muslim,
world.
Um,
three events in 1956 harden the lines
between the [inaudible] that is the
settlers,
uh,
and,
[inaudible] fighting for independence.
On the February 6th,
the mob in Algiers and greeted the
French premiere who's called Muhly,
uh,
m,
O,
l,
e t a,
and his choice,
uh,
for,
Governor General,
uh,
who was considered by the
Colo to be to pro Arab,
and they greet him with rotten eggs,
uh,
and with,
tomatoes.
Uh,
and it's a very nasty scene and moldy
capitulates and appoints a socialist,
uh,
more,
strident on,
on the issue of holding onto Algeria,
uh,
as governor general.
Um,
in October,
uh,
in 1956,
there's a conference between the Saltin
of Morocco and the leader of the Flna
leader of the FLN.
In Tunisia.
There's,
there's,
uh,
outrage in,
the French right wing,
a press.
And so a French authorities had,
uh,
the most important
delegate at this meeting.
A guy called Ben Bella,
who is still alive.
B E N,
I just looked the other day to see a,
and I think he's still alive.
He was born in something like 19,
19,
if I remember correctly.
They have him kidnapped,
uh,
and put in a jail near Paris.
Uh,
it,
the,
uh,
they began to repress critics of this
rather bold and totally illegal act,
uh,
and launch a and C's books that are,
against,
um,
against this movement.
And then in November,
as some of you know,
uh,
the French government
participates in the whole,
um,
uh,
Suez Canal mess,
in part because,
uh,
Egypt,
and we'll see this in a minute,
at least briefly,
uh,
was an important part of,
of,
uh,
generating a sympathy for,
the Algerian,
uh,
national,
resistance,
uh,
movements.
Um,
and,
uh,
the British and the French and bay.
There's a cease fire that's,
that's for,
that's a forced by,
um,
uh,
Russia when the Soviet
Union with the aid of,
of,
uh,
of the United States.
Uh,
and this seems to be another,
a humiliation and what this does
as it begins to harden the lines.
Now the problem with,
you know,
with all of this is,
is as again,
as the army,
um,
is that now it looks again
from the point of view of the,
of the,
the,
the high command in the
army that that again,
uh,
the civilians are going to capitulate
and there'll be some humiliating
withdrawal from Algeria as
there had been from Vietnam.
But it's a very different cost,
isn't it?
Because you've got a million Frenchmen
in quotes as they see themselves.
They know.
They didn't accept the,
you know,
the Frenchness of,
of,
of the other.
As they saw the,
unfortunately I saw the,
the,
the Arab population is the army
going to be disgraced again now,
um,
the,
again,
World War Two and the defeat in
1940 and people could remember that,
has to be seen as a background and
the defeat in Vietnam in eight,
in 1958,
the average military officer had spent
at least one 30 months tour of duty in
Indochina.
And the average military officer had
spent two to four years now Juriah along
with a small tour of the occupying,
you know,
garrisons in West Germany.
But,
but support was wavering for the war.
Citations for wounded soldiers stopped
appearing in the official journal is
you're now with CCL.
20,000 French soldiers
had died in Vietnam.
Uh,
that's a lot.
Um,
9,000,
I had died,
uh,
by 1958 in Algeria.
And so there are charges of abandonment
and hatred of the officers of the French
Communist Party,
which seemed to be orchestrating
among other people,
orchestrating and along
with the intellectuals,
opposition to the war.
And then there was the issue of torture,
how topical again,
uh,
in our,
contemporary,
the world in which we lived,
um,
the army had raised,
revived an old concept of what they
consider to be the real country,
the true country,
the true France,
if you will,
representing the real interests of France.
That is the army.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the,
the legal country,
which was,
you know,
included some of those people who,
uh,
who,
who opposed them.
Um,
and so,
um,
within the army and there
begin to be not only a discord,
but attempts to organize,
uh,
a right wing groups that
became known as the OAS,
the secret army that eventually tries
to kill Charles de Gaulle himself and
launches a campaign of terror in France.
Uh,
and things that,
that you can read about.
They try a pooch,
uh,
in,
in 1961.
Sometimes I used to
show this film in here,
but it's the torture scene is too
hard to see and people used to leave.
Uh,
it's horrible,
but it's one of the great movies made in,
uh,
you know,
in our lifetimes.
It's the battle of Algiers,
the battle of Algiers.
Absolutely fantastic.
The scene where the woman with a bomb
goes into a cafe and places the bomb and
looks at families who personally she
has nothing against and she knows that
they're going to blow up and be killed.
It's one of the great scenes in,
uh,
in,
in film,
uh,
and it,
you think it's a documentary,
but it's not.
And this is about the French
war against the Cosby,
against the,
the Algerian quarters.
Uh,
and these two worlds,
the French Cologne worlds
and the cafes of the Cologne,
their extension would
be the port of mouth,
say the old port of Maasais and,
uh,
and the world of people,
in the casbah.
And so what the military wants
to do is they want to break,
uh,
the pair of the Political
Military Organization of,
of the insurgence.
And they want to do this
through state terror.
So you have the terror of those who
are accused of being terrorists,
who are blowing up cafes as the
independence movement did in,
in Vietnam.
And the state,
uh,
terror involving a systematic torture,
the murder,
the slaughter of,
of,
uh,
a very,
ordinary people,
many of whom had nothing
to do with anything.
And their response is repression
first,
second.
This is from a book by Chillner,
I think.
I can't remember.
He lists these things,
uh,
on the army.
Uh,
a totalitarian,
a technique of organization,
a promising,
some reform,
but basically just organizing,
uh,
a basically a military state,
the political activism of the army,
thus,
uh,
the Oh Aas,
and working on the French population
as a whole to argue that those who are
against these measures being taken by
the French army in the name of France are
disloyal and do not represent,
uh,
the,
the true France,
the real France as they,
uh,
they see it.
Um,
and so the cycle of violence,
uh,
is,
totally,
uh,
I is totally untenable.
And,
um,
oh,
you know,
what?
The intellectuals,
uh,
get,
involved,
um,
uh,
come to add about outcome.
You and,
and lots of others,
uh,
organized opposition to the torture.
Ah,
AH,
the two,
this repression to these mass murderers,
I,
and,
uh,
the stakes,
increase,
uh,
dramatically.
I N it is,
um,
yeah,
it,
it is,
uh,
a total,
total,
uh,
chaos.
Can you,
who was born in Algeria,
um,
described the difficult choices for
French families who lived in Algeria.
Uh,
you know,
the vast majority were not in
favor of mass murder and torture.
Uh,
he said if he was given the choice
between justice and his mother,
he would take his mother.
But lots of people,
there were again,
these cafe owners where people of
modest means who are simply caught,
uh,
in,
you know,
in the middle of all of this now,
ah,
in on March 13th,
1958,
a protest demonstration
by French settlers,
the Cola in Algiers turned into a
military red led insurrection against the
French government,
a committee of public safety,
but not a left wing one,
but a right wing one,
uh,
of rightest,
seized power.
Ah,
Eh,
this is in Algeria.
And there was a distinct possibility
of a military coup d'etat in France.
I have a friend called Murray scalp
down who's been in the ministry.
He's now retired,
but as an academic.
And when he was in the
army back in those days,
he was in Dijon and they had,
or he was in the air
force and he had that,
they were told to park planes
on the runways in digital.
Uh,
and this happened in very many
places in France because it was,
it seemed quite likely that the Aha that
is the French paratroopers were going
to be landing and that there
would be civil war in France,
uh,
between the army.
Uh,
and those army elements that
didn't go along with all of this.
And those,
uh,
you know,
intellectuals and the,
and the communists and the Socialists
and all these other people,
though a lot of the socialists were
quite ambivalent about all of this.
No.
Charles de Gaulle who had gone off to
his small house in a place called Colon
Bay,
and they do a Zig Lee's,
uh,
after he didn't get his way,
as you know,
uh,
right after a world war two,
I announced that he was
ready to serve France again.
Uh,
many politicians who had real reasons
to fear a seizure of power by the
military.
Uh,
they believe that only the towering
figure of Charles de Gaulle could save
France.
And on May 29th,
1958 present [inaudible] c o t y
perfume appointed to Gaul premier,
uh,
moved,
point,
uh,
approved by the National
Assembly in early June.
He accepted,
uh,
but on condition that he could rule for
by emergency to cre for six months and
then ask the nation to
approve a new constitution.
Now,
de Gaulle had always insisted that France
needed a stronger executive authority
that the third republic I had
fallen basically because no,
there weren't any strong leaders to make
what he considered the right decisions
in the 1930s.
But because of the fear of
Caesar Ism of Napoleon's,
of boodle and Jay,
and have these kinds of strong types
or a Vichy for that matter of Peyto,
uh,
the president of France
had very little power.
Power remained,
remained in the chamber,
uh,
in the Chamber of Deputies.
Now the right,
including the army was
delighted to have de Gaulle,
the big guy,
uh,
serving in what they assumed would be
a more or less permanent or lengthy
capacity until a new constitution with
a strong executive authority could be
written.
He was one of theirs.
He was wounded on a bridge and
[inaudible] not the two French denom,
but dino in a,
with a t in,
in Belgium,
uh,
at the very beginning of war war two,
he was born,
had been born in the
fortress town of Lean,
not too far away from,
uh,
the big garrisons and the big fort there
and surely to Gaul would want Algeria
to remain,
uh,
to remain French would need now the new
constitution increase the authority of
the president.
It was written by Michelle deploy.
Hey,
by the way,
whose son is a very important,
uh,
gall is oil,
no stone called Gaullist anymore,
but,
um,
uh,
on paid leader in,
in France.
Now what it did is it set it,
set the term of the
presidency at seven years,
it's gone back to five now and
ended the revolving door ministries,
uh,
and presence under the
Fifth Republic could,
uh,
now,
you know,
conduct foreign policy.
They appoint prime ministers and
they can dissolve parliament.
Uh,
in September,
1958,
80% of the population approve the
constitution of the fifth republic.
But what about Algeria?
Now the Algerian situation was different
than any other war of independence that
had been fought before.
And there was an internationalization of
that war is a brilliant book on this by
a guy called Matthew Connolly,
who was a,
who teaches at Columbia,
who was a graduate student here.
And what the,
the,
the National Liberation Front
in Algeria was able to do,
was to mobilize newspapers,
uh,
of the left end of the center.
Uh,
and to use the sort of publicity
machine to excite worldwide attention,
uh,
against,
against torture,
against the abuses of civilian.
There was an internet nationalization
of that war and this goes a long way to
try to,
uh,
help the situation of the,
of the rebels of the surgeons in,
uh,
in Algeria.
Now.
Um,
so what's he going to do?
And so on the 4th of June,
1958,
he goes to LGS and he's welcomed by,
by the throngs,
not the Algerians,
but the cone.
Oh,
by the way,
the Harkema the,
the hockey two names.
I need to explain the hierarchy where
the Algerians who fought for the French
and if they stayed in
Algeria after the war,
they are toast.
And so they,
and then the French,
what they did is they brought them back
and put them in a not really internment
camps,
but sort of they put them into uh,
into areas,
can reserved areas for them.
And of course their relations with
other Algerians are not very good.
Uh,
and it's a very awkward situation.
The other name here is my sue,
who is one of the chief torturers,
uh,
in the who just died a couple years ago,
in the army.
So he goes to Algeria and he says he
gives his classic speech of noncommittal.
He told the settlers on the 4th of June,
1958 I have understood you,
I know what you have tried to do here,
but he had already decided that the
cost of France continuing the war was to
grow,
were too great,
that the war was to decisive.
And he removed many of the generals
responsible for the coup d'etat in Algeria
from their post for somebody
for whom nationalism,
as we'll see on Wednesday,
underlie underlay his
basic philosophy of life.
This seemed to be an
astonishing turnaround,
a stab in the back by a military man.
And as the Dreyfus affair had revealed,
had revealed in the 1890s and the Vichy
years had confirmed a right wing anti
democratic tradition survived
in the officer Corps Corps.
And so they felt absolutely betrayed.
And so the OAS,
which had already,
but we're already existed in reality,
they try to kill the gall.
The closest they get a is at
a place called [inaudible]
clay come out outside of
Paris where they machine gun,
uh,
his big limousine and they're,
you know,
20 or 30 bullet holes in there.
And it's hard to miss a guy
who was her power forward size.
Uh,
you know,
six,
seven,
huge,
huge man,
but he emerges unscathed.
There was absolutely incredible.
And the plant bombs in Paris,
this is terrorism to blow up
and to terrorize the population.
The goal assumes,
uh,
assumes,
emergency powers again
this time for a year,
but not in the interest of the army.
His interest is to pull France.
This is the ultimate in reality.
Politique,
uh,
is to pull France out of Algeria and
there's a volt for Algerian independence
held in 1961 in July and 15 million
vote week and 5 million vote no,
and there's a new attempt in Algeria
by army officers to organize an
insurrection and as soon put put down,
uh,
and um,
Algeria becomes free.
Now in the last minute.
That remains me to me that I have left.
One of the things that is interesting
now in the last 20 years is that when the
national front,
the right wing party of John,
now he looked Penn who had
demisse dismissed by the way,
the death camps and the
Holocaust is a minor detail.
I'm quoting him exactly.
And who applauded the drowning of
immigrants in the San River by his thugs.
Uh,
when he,
when he first came to the attention
of the world with a see a series of
astonishing electoral victories or at
least a good showings in various places in
France.
One of the things that people first
who followed at first noted is that he
didn't do that well and the tradition
anymore than anywhere else in the more
traditionally Catholic parts of France.
That is Brittany or one of the departments
where we had his first big success,
a near shot two in a
place called [inaudible],
but the places that he
did astoundingly well,
we're on the Mediterranean
and in the volt clues.
That is where avenue is and our launch.
Why it's not the,
the large immigrant populations from
North Africa who are voting for somebody
that wants to drown them or send
them back to where they came from.
They're not voting for him.
The people that voted for him
massively are the Cologne,
the PN.
Wow.
Not all of them,
but it was they who had to leave in
1960 and 61 and 62 in many cases,
getting out,
quick packing up photos,
whatever they could take
with them in some cases,
extreme cases and going to
France where they bought cafes,
orange groves,
et cetera.
And they remembered and they hate it.
And that's what changes did change the
inner dramatic way in area that had
always been left wing,
at least since the middle
of the 19th century.
And turns it into the bastion of
for awhile of the National Front.
And then things got more complicated.
But it went back to these events in,
uh,
in Algeria.
And what happened there
that shaped not only France,
but movements in other countries.
See you on Wednesday.